but I made a movie I make a lot of
movies but my most recent one was called
30-100 run and become it's out on Amazon
it's gonna be out on Amazon Prime in the
UK in a couple of weeks it's about the
world's longest running race I would say
that my expertise has just been cleaned
by spending a lot of time with people
who don't just look at running as
performance or look at running as
fitness but look at running the way that
humanity did thousands of years ago that
running is in fact a pathway to self
transformation to self-realization and
if you believe in something higher to
the divine
I am joined by Sanjay rael Sanjay
welcome the show Chris it's great to be
on your show thanks for having me
absolutely pleasure to have you on
before we get started even for the
listeners at home behind Sanjay in
wherever he's filming is a series of
like mannequins slightly sullen
sad-looking mannequins and a really epic
is that a painting of some falconry but
where are you what's what's that what's
that backdrop I'm in my edit studio in
New York City and I have a garden right
outside and a friend of mine made a
series of sculptures which aren't
finished yet and they were all sitting
in my backyard but the weather is turned
here and I had to bring them all inside
so I don't know if people are familiar
with the Terracotta Warriors of GM a
farmer discovered in his field thousands
of clay statues all pointed in the right
direction I kind of feel like that's
where I'm sitting right now I've got
these replica statues of the Indian
meditation teacher Sri Chinmoy
meditating and it feels like I'm in a
temple it's pretty epic it's as
backdrops goemon that's that's not bad
so for the listeners who don't know who
you are how would you how would you
describe yourself and give us a bit of
background T so number one if there is a
listener who knows who I am
oh my god I want to meet them I'm nobody
I'm a jack of all trades master of none
but I made a movie I make a lot of
movies but my most recent one was called
3100 run and become its out on Amazon
it's gonna be out on Amazon Prime in the
UK in a couple of weeks it's about the
world's longest running race I would say
that my expertise has just been cleaned
by spending a lot of time with people
who don't just look at running as
performance or look at running as
fitness but look at running the way that
humanity did thousands of years ago that
running is in fact a pathway to self
transformation to self-realization and
if you believe in something higher to
the divine why running well this is
interesting
because there's a famous book by a good
friend of mine Chris McDougall born to
run and he explored the anthropological
connection between human evolution and
running and evolutionary biologist
suggests that the advantage the only
advantage that early men and women had
on the savanna amongst massive predators
amongst massive herbivores was the fact
that we could move on two feet
now physiologically that means that when
we walk our breath is not coupled to our
gait if you can imagine a quadruped and
you know when they extend out their
lungs inflate well they breathe is that
how that breathing hayden's works no way
I never knew that when their four legs
collapse their entire torso collapses
and the air is expelled and so they are
not good aerobic runners because they
have to - they can't regulate their
breathing we can breathe a lot more we
can breathe two or three or four times
per step if we need to they can't so
even if they're going slow they can't
breathe a couple times so they're not
good slow runners so we were great slow
runners and in 3101 to come we actually
went to the Kalahari Desert to live and
hunt with the San Bushmen who've been
around for a hundred and twenty-five
thousand years and you and I don't look
like San Bushmen but and not to say that
they're the root tribe of everyone but
they were perhaps the most eager tribe
because every single human being has
markers in their DNA distinguished only
by the connection to San Bushmen like we
all have a piece of their DNA in us so
they've been around for a long time and
people have gone and studied them and
Chris McDougall looked at looked at them
and born to run and said well we were
born to run because our evolutionary
advantage on the savanna was our ability
to chase animals down for 24-48 hours
totally exhausting with the rudimentary
weapons and no weaponry at all we could
approach dehy
rated animals kill them take them home
but the reality was far more interesting
you know when we kind of presented these
outside Western theories to the Bushmen
they kind of looked at us with with just
in they were they were incredulous they
say that humanity evolves because of
consciousness not because of form they
said that their ability to track and
catch large game was not due to the fact
that they were endurance maniacs it was
due to the fact that human beings can
pray they can pray a lot more deeply
than lesser evolved primates they said
that they understood prayer they
understood how they could gather energy
from the earth and that is what carried
them to catch animals and so they say
the cosmology developed before the
actual practice developed they got the
energy they realized what they could do
with it and so from the very very
beginning running and human spirituality
went hand in hand so in that sense
running was was the first religion of
humanity
that's a lovely a very transcendent very
this for something that for a lot of
people I suppose running would be a
function of your lactate threshold times
by your via vo2 max plus your running
efficiency etc etc to hear something
that's a lot more spiritually guided is
is quite interesting quite meaningful
you know people can get what they want
to out of physical activity but if you
want to look really good physical
fitness will get you there if you want
to become really healthy physical
fitness running or anything will get you
there it's all matter of intention you
know with running if you want to
transform your life and if you go into
running with that intention it will get
you there I mean you can see what Elliot
Kip show gays run last weekend over and
over and over and all of his interviews
he touches on the idea of faith he
touches on the idea that humanity has no
limits that's not just philosophy for
him it's an idea that he's seen he lived
he's got faith in it it's like his faith
in the the transcendent capacity of
human beings gave him the vision and one
would argue gave him the capacity or
helped in his capacity to reach that
two-hour run if that's not the
combination of running and spirituality
I don't know what is in our movie 3100
runner to come we focus on the world's
longest running race which is a 3100
mile race that takes place solely around
a 1/2 mile loop on a block in New York
City it's been going on every year for
the last 23 years 10 to 15 people
attempt it every year and they have to
average almost 100k 59 point eight miles
per day for 52 straight days and some
people the course record for the men is
77 miles per day so nearly three
marathons a day for in that case forty
days there's two questions like why
would anybody do that number one number
two how is it possible I mean the more
interesting one is like why would
anybody do it and this is the heart of
running it's like if you run for an hour
or two hours or a day you're running
with suffering you're running with pain
you're pushing but once you start
entering races that are 2 days 3 days 6
days like looking at the at them at the
example of a Bushman hunt which might
take 2 3 4 days of constant slow aerobic
told running that you not you know you
don't have a lot of aerobic output
you're not you know generating lactic
acid it's very calm
it's very meditative when you're in that
type of running the mind shuts down the
mind turns off and you begin to
naturally experience a lot of the
emotion a lot of the flow that you can
experience in silent contemplator
practices like meditation so the running
actually becomes an experience of bliss
and what becomes immaterial are your
surroundings the only things that you
need are water food 10,000 calories a
day is what they take water food shelter
and having all those things around a
half mile loop takes away a lot of those
issues as opposed to running across the
United States for example well that's
one of the primary drivers behind some
Tibetan Buddhist practices right that
you do something which allows the front
of the mind to be occupied like cleaning
or washing up or tending to a garden
which frees up the remainder of the mind
to be liberated into a space which gives
it more freedom to think I mean that
that's that's the training and you can
see the Kip chug is a master of it in
fact the Kenyans say that if you want to
run well you have to run dumb do UMB
it's like you have to be totally soft
between your ears if you think you're
screwed number one it's not that
thinking is bad but once you stop
thinking the actual power of the
spiritual heart the actual power of the
body moves unimpeded and it's not a
question of like mind over matter it's
getting rid of your mind
like when Kip toga says human beings are
unlimited he's not talking about the
mind the mind is incredibly limited it's
always telling us what we can do and
what we can't do it's always measuring
it's saying that two hours is impossible
you can't use that kind of a tool you
have to get it out of the way and so
when Kenyans regularly train and the
Ethiopians and great marathoners will
train to be in the mind of meditation to
completely have a silent experience
within yourself to look at breathing
as the song your heartbeat as a song and
learning to recognize the cues that your
body is ready and willing to push harder
than you could imagine there's a number
of athletes that I know in the CrossFit
community is a good example of this one
wire your ability to deal with
discomfort sometimes for prolonged
periods of time longer workout so you
know up to half an hour to maybe even an
hour and I have to say that most of the
best athletes that I know and not
massively cerebral with their approach
Matt Fraser
for example fitness man on the planet
probably greatest CrossFit who has ever
lived so far he's not massively cerebral
he has strict rules that he sticks to
and holds himself to an ruthlessly high
standard but I think that once he's done
his preparation he then allows his
performance to simply be the stage upon
which all of this preparation gets to
present itself I don't I totally get the
analogy as well with Kipchoge effort
people who are listening that don't know
about him he lives this like monastic
lifestyle he sees running as his sort of
the highest form of what it is that he
can present to the world so yeah yeah
it's very interesting how all of these
different things piece together so I
mean the first question apart from why
does someone want to do it before that
my question before why does someone want
to do the 30 100 races why New York you
know that the race was started by an
Indian spiritual teacher Sri Chinmoy
and three two more came from India to
New York in the 60s and he was really at
the heart of the running boom in the 70s
I mean if you can imagine New York in
the 70s the 1977 and 1978 New York City
marathons were actually begun with Sri
Chinmoy doing a meditation you know in
front of thousands and thousands of
runners the day before they held a
meditation in Central Park
he was at the heart of that running
movement and as people began to desire
more distance than just 26 miles you
know he became one of the prime sponsors
of 24-hour races 48-hour races six-day
races 10-day races and by the mid
nineties people were clamoring for those
experiences of self transcendence and it
was pushed at 31
hundred miles the logistics are quite
complex and it's one of those things
that for those of your listeners who
have been to New York City they'll
understand that there's really no other
place in the world where this is
possible I mean that that's primarily it
it's like even though you're you're
running you know on a city street on a
sidewalk around a school for you know 18
hours a day the energy of the city and
the vibration of the city is actually
conducive to helping you when you're in
your most exhausted state but you know
speaking about monastic traditions in
3101 and become we actually spent time
with a very elusive sect of runners in
central Japan outside a city called
Kyoto and their group were the first
that brought Buddhism from China to
Japan and in that first year that they
brought Buddhism to Japan they started
something called a thousand day Trek now
people can go to our Instagram account
at 3100 film and see that these monks
look like they're out of Star Wars
they're draped head-to-toe and white
bamboo sandals staff like long
cylindrical hat so they pick one
aspirant every 7 years people have to
put their math hats on one aspirant
every 7 years to do a thousand days of
trekking those thousand days are split
into ten hundred day chunks the first so
you've got seven years to do it so some
years you're doing one cycle of a
hundred days some years you're doing two
cycles but each cycle has a set daily
mileage now they're on a mountain so
it's like the first couple of years
first couple of cycles they have to do
about 11.6 miles per day which involves
going up and down a thousand meter
mountain at once they're not running but
their pace going up that mountain is
faster than most people could run it but
by the time they get to the seventh and
eighth cycle they're at 35 miles per day
the ninth and tenth cycle
they're at 56 miles per day now they go
into it with the idea that this is going
to be an experience of bliss and
experience of prayer and experience of
meditation that's what they train for
that's what their minds and their heart
two prepared for but here's the kicker
if they don't finish any single day's
mileage they have to take their lives
like no one's had to take their life in
about 150 years but that's the ultimate
price that's that's the sacrifice of
this hardship and one would say like
what that kind of consequence hanging
over your head how could you not but
move in fear but it's the opposite it's
like you know there is that consequence
but that keeps your intent pure that
makes you realize that this is a sacred
opportunity I can only do this if I
remain in the mind and heart of
meditation so in the movie it's like we
explore these root cultures that Navajo
and other southwestern Native American
tribes in the United States the sound
Bushmen these monks in Japan to really
show how and why extreme physical
fitness or extreme achievement through
the body is not only possible it's one
of the most natural things that human
beings can do it's really epic hearing
about it's you know conjuring up these
images of these monks going up and down
this mountain in service of you know
their higher the higher sense of self
searching for self transcendence and
using it as this meditative practice it
does it makes things like the Olympics
feel quite impure weirdly actually feels
quite glitzy and sort of glamorous in a
way that this doesn't well so that the
the experience that I had I used to be a
semi competitive runner but never really
put one and one together until I started
spending time with these cultures that
have run and looked at spirit the
spirituality of sports for thousands of
years we all experienced these things
you know in a workout or maybe in a race
the beauty of connecting with these
cultures and what we tried to show and
3101 and to come is we try to give
people the language to understand their
own experiences to deepen their own
experiences and to understand that
physical fitness can actually be a
spiritual path I mean if you look at the
Spartans if you look at like the roots
of the Olympics the idea of faster
higher stronger that's self
transcendence you know we met a Hopi
elder in in Arizona who said on a
morning run that we were doing he said
the translation was find joy through
exertion a man named Rex tylium Tewa
fine joy through exertion that means
like in your most quote unquote painful
moments when we are thinking that all
bur experiencing is suffering you know
he exhorted us to flip that experience
to deny the the strength of that
suffering and to realize that there's a
deep joy in that idea of exertion we
have to go beyond the concept of pain
defining exertion and let joy be the
overflowing emotion that we feel in
exertion you can't achieve that in a
race you can't hope that once you get to
that at the performance level in a
CrossFit competition or in a running
race that you're magically going to be
able to experience that it's something
that needs to be done not just in
training but it needs to be your mindset
and you can see that if your goal is
self transcendence and you focus your
entire training around that it can't but
be a spiritual path it's a very
beautiful way of putting it I wouldn't I
wouldn't how many people that are
listening understand what we mean when
we say about the pain into joy sensation
I think if you're not massively familiar
with a meditative practice or doing
things similar to that it might sound a
little bit alien but there's a quote
from Sam Harris that I always remember
when we talk about long seated
meditation postures so I did a
meditation retreat with my friend in
between Christmas and New Year at a
Tibetan temple not far from here and as
a part of that we did a seated
meditation for 90 minutes which isn't
that long it was part of a much longer
meditation for the whole day but being
sat cross-legged on the floor for 90
minutes I got like that
Titus hips in the world is ruthless and
there's this quote from Sam Harris where
he talks about when he was doing it and
he said after a while he couldn't work
out whether the pain in his hip was
absolute agony or complete ecstasy and
when you spend sufficient time around
the sensation and you begin to imagine
it and break it apart into its component
pieces you actually realize that the
difference between a lot of pain and a
lot of ecstasy a the line becomes
incredibly blurred doesn't it
III agree and III think that we
experience things as pain when fear is
involved when fear is not involved it's
an entirely different sensation and
that's the difference between the mind
and the heart when you're in the mind
when you're thinking you're
rationalizing you're measuring
you're contemplating like how many of us
in our routines are in the moment like
I'm looking at my GPS watch what I'm
running I'm thinking about what I'm
gonna do afterwards I'm thinking about
what I'm gonna eat what the rest of my
day is like the splits I'm trying to
achieve the time I'm trying to achieve
in the run I'm not focusing on my breath
my mind is in the way
the question for listener is is how do
you get the mind out of the way like you
have to enter into the heart into into
the spiritual heart into the area that
we point to as you know when we say like
I'm Chris or I'm Sanjay and that's done
through practice through seated
meditation or really through
understanding simple breathing
techniques understanding how to breathe
in peace how to release anxiety how to
imagine that the breath isn't just
coming in through our nose or through
our mouth but it's actually coming into
our hearts when you start feeling the
breathing sensation happening here and
the energy flow happening here it
becomes easier to practice that while
you're competing while you're training
and so it's like we have to get out of
the minds once we get out of the minds
and into the heart fear isn't there
what's in the heart loves in the heart
Joy's in the heart peace is in the heart
and I'm not not to say that the minds
not going to come back every second or
every minute to be to remind us that
it's there but the more we can get into
our heart the more we can slow down our
breathing
the more we can relax the less actual
physical pain enters into us but when it
comes we learn to breathe it out we
learn to collect that anxiety to breathe
it out that nervous tension which causes
pain to breathe it out
that comes from practice and that comes
from looking at the intention behind it
it's like if we want to be in the heart
then we have to practice being in the
heart another Sam Harris is and my
feeling I'm quoting him directly today
I'm beaming Sam Harris straight into my
brain at the moment another thing that
he says to the listeners who might be
thinking well it's all well and good but
I've been in some real real amounts of
discomfort and pain you can't tell me
that that's not just pure pain in itself
perfect example that he uses is the way
that you feel when you're in the middle
of a workout you don't feel pain in the
middle of a workout because you know why
it's happening and because the direction
that you are moving in is something
that's satisfying however if you were
just laid in bed and woke up in the
middle of the night sweating with your
heart racing at the same place as it
would imagine that you took that
physiological state that you had in
training and moved it into your body
when you were asleep
you'd think what is going on like am I
having a heart attack
is this a exciting attack I'm having a
breakdown is this a stroke like what's
going on and you're totally right the
difference between how we interpret the
sensations that we have going on in our
body determines a lot about how what we
can do with those sensations what one of
the things that you mentioned there was
taking our focus outside of the brain
outside of the mind into the heart and
into the task that's in hand do you
think that the short route which will
inevitably become very repetitive if
it's a half mile you're going to be
doing it 6,200 laps or so during this
particular race is that helping is that
contributing to it the fact that there
is it there's no novelty or intensity
that's going past with regards to the
surrounding you're just focused on the
task at hand that's a great question so
you know a lot of scientists and a lot
of people that have been on your show
I've talked about the idea of flow like
flow isn't static right like flow is
next
of momentum and when your focus on the
task at hand it seems like the first
step is concentration and it is but the
second step is generating this dynamic
flow of energy from your heart and when
you get into that state everything is
new around you like each moment is new
it's not like 1 step 2 step 3 step 4
step because people have to take more
than a million steps across the 3,100
miles and that would drive you mad so
it's the idea of generating a certain
type of energy from the heart that makes
you spontaneously and naturally happy
like you know in anything in life when
you're naturally happy like the minute
the measurement the hours of miles they
fly by when you're in a calm relaxed
state of mind you can have intensity in
the heart and you can be pushing and you
can be flowing and it's great it's an
incredible sensation and you want to
push harder to get more of it that
that's that's that's what I'm talking
about and what I'm suggesting you know
when we spend time and what one of our
characters Sean Martin who is a Navajo
ultra-marathoner Sean was the first
person who totally flipped the switch in
my mind we went out for a morning run I
was waiting for my GPS watch to connect
in between these canyon walls we're in
this epic Canyon that's completely new
to me
he runs it every day and so keep that in
mind but once we set up for the morning
run I realized he was enjoying it more
than me and he was getting more out of
it than I ever could he was relaxed he
was calm he was open and when I asked
him afterwards why he looked like he was
enjoying it more than me he said look
number one for the Navajo and for a lot
of indigenous tribes running is a
celebration of life it's like you feel
the energy of nature whether you're
running on a sidewalk or in a canyon if
your feet are on the ground you're
running on Mother Earth you're
surrounded by sky even if you're in a
gym it's like air is sky you're
surrounded by those same energies
running
a celebration of those energies number
two running is a teacher it's like you
don't go to your teacher and say like
these are all my problems I'm gonna talk
to you for two hours you have to listen
to your teacher so running allows you to
listen it really gives you the
perspective on your own problems on your
own Joy's on your own sufferings but and
this is what got me number three he said
running as a prayer when your feet are
running on Mother Earth they're praying
when you're breathing you're breathing
in father sky so when you run your feet
are praying to mother earth you're
breathing in father sky you just show
what you're praying to them for their
blessings and you're showing them
through the act of running that you're
willing to work for those blessings
you're asking and you're receiving
compassion from all the divinity that
surrounds you and he said take it or
leave it
that's the reality it's like if somebody
tells if I take a spurt aspartate in my
whole life and someone says sugar is
better I'm gonna say I've never tried
sugar there's no way it can be better
right but it's like once you've tasted
sugar you know it's the reality and so
he's like take it or leave it but this
is the reality it's not a matter of
belief and the more we went back into
traditional cultures the more we
realized that was the root of the human
experience it's like when you dance on
the earth when you move on the earth
when you walk when you run when you lift
it's like you can channel those energies
just by the humility of recognizing that
your feet on this gigantic being that
you're breathing in this entity and you
become larger-than-life you hit that
that realm of where you understand that
you're not as limited as you think you
are and so going back to gift Cho gay
it's like what he says about breaking
the 2-hour barrier that no human is
unlimited
that's echoed in traditional cultures
all over the world you can certainly see
people who are living in synchronicity
with their surroundings with a higher
purpose
you know kids okay to me you see him
and he is just a man that is living in
alignment with everything that he needs
to do it's like when he walks when you
see him at the start of the race perfect
example if anyone wants to go and have a
look at the start of the India's 1:59
challenge and you see him and he sort of
he's behind the guys and he walks
through their parting in the barriers
behind he takes this little step through
and it feels that watching it it feels
like the universe just part around him
and he he just moves through it like a
fish through water he moves through the
universe the universe moves around him
he's just I love watching him I find him
I find him fascinating human to watch so
getting on to the actual 3100 race take
us through so you've said it's in it's
in New York around it around a block
where when and why let's let's let's hit
it so it's in Queens New York City it
happens during the most brutal time of
the year it happens in June July and
part of August
it's a fifty-two day race so nearly
eight week period New York City is a big
city a lot of people you have to get
permits to do things like this can't get
a permit in a park for 52 days so this
happens to take place around a high
school on a relatively flat loop
although when you're doing that many
miles all the the ups and downs add up
people have to be at the course at 6:00
a.m. for the start the quarry day every
day the course is open for 18 hours a
day they can stay till midnight or they
can leave their rrv set up on the course
for people to take breaks most people
will take about 30 to 45 minutes of
breaks across those 18 hours there is an
aid station set up at the start and
finish of the other half mile loop that
is just filled with stuff like there's
be there's meals cooked all day long
because each runner needs to take
between ten and fourteen thousand
calories per day now ten thousand
calories is the equivalent of about a
hundred and eighty eggs like it's a lot
it's a lot of food how do they do that
if they're only taking thirty minutes to
45 minutes of a break within an 18
period - they eating constantly yeah
it's so it's like the thing about ultra
distance running is that pace at any one
moment is determined by the course it's
like if you're going downhill on a
mountain you're flying if you're going
uphill you know up a big mountain you're
you're walking so this course is a
rectangle and people can imagine that
there's a slight downhill going one way
a slight uphill going the other way they
can switch directions every day that's
the only variation so people tend to run
the downhills probably at eight to ten
minute per mile pace they'll walk all
the corners they'll walk the uphills so
it might take someone anywhere between
seven and anywhere between six and eight
minutes to do a full lap and along the
way they might be eating they might be
drinking people have to take about 20
liters of water five gallons or so of
water a day across the day they're
trying to do about 60 miles and that
puts you just on the edge people are
generally trying to do 60 to 65 some are
doing 7075 so it's not like they're
pushing it all day long and this type of
a race you can't push it all day long
you have to be at a state where you can
do 70 miles and then believe it or not
recover overnight on 4 or 5 hours of
sleep and then get up the next morning
and do 70 more miles for 45 days or so
so that's about about 4 miles an
hour-ish ish it's like four miles an
hour with your brakes
we'll get you 60 miles a day but you
know 4 miles an hour is a fast walk yeah
so do a fast walk for an hour you go
okay that was a fast walk try doing it
for 15 or 16 hours so most people will
jog and then shuffle and then jog and
then shuffle they're not breaking any
speed barriers but the best the best
people in the in the best people who've
run the best times have all achieved
pretty fast marathons pretty fast 50 and
hundred mile races
apart from the 3100 so their competence
across a range of distances then yeah
but they tend to get better as the
distance gets longer mm-hmm it was
interesting I was watching a an analysis
of Kip Chagas performance last week and
they were talking about the fact that I
think he he was at the Olympics is he
was he in the 5000 meters yeah but he
performed like okay but they didn't even
get selected for Kenya at 2012 and then
2016 he wasn't even in the Olympic squad
and he found of something like that and
he found that his longer distances were
really where he came into his own and
then when he transitioned to road
running well he was an incredible three
thousand five thousand ten thousand
meter runner like he wasn't he wasn't
the all-time best like Kenenisa Bekele
but he moved pretty effortlessly to the
marathon there are some people that have
that have been great 10k runners that
haven't moved that effortlessly yeah I
get it
so getting onto the race itself it
starts with a one minute meditation yeah
every morning at 6 a.m. there's a short
meditation and I can't say how focused
people are cos if you if you if you
watch the movie and you see how they
look at 6:00 a.m. they looks like it
looks like a war zone it generally takes
about an hour for people to warm up
everyone for the most part will pound
like Starbucks double-shot cans of
coffee to just get everything going
between 6 a.m. and 11 a.m. the
temperature is pretty tolerable in
Fahrenheit it'll be between 60 and 68
Fahrenheit I guessing like 13 Celsius or
so but between 11 and 6 p.m. it can
climb to 32 c 34 c 36 c so you're
talking 96 98 a hundred degrees that's
pretty so so in terms of pacing after
the first hour of warm-up people are
trying to get their miles in before
10:00 or 11:00 and then from 10 and 10
or 11 until 6 p.m. or so they're just
moving they don't care whether they're
walking or they're
they're moving there it's survival mode
and then from 6:00 p.m. to midnight
you're trying to really push towards
your daily mile goals who are the
superstars of this particular sport of
this particular race so the star of our
movie 3100 runner become is a diminutive
finished paperboy probably the best
paperboy in the world what a selection
of characteristics I know his name is
Ashe Breanna Alto but he loves being a
postal and paperboy postal and paper
deliverer
because he's on his feet 1012 hours a
day so it's incredible training he has
run the race 15 times ok that means he's
done forty six and a half thousand miles
around this half mile loop like most
people haven't run forty six and a half
thousand miles in their life I mean
doing forty six and a half thousand
miles is basically like running a
hundred miles a week every week of the
year for like eight and a half years
isn't the same the circumference of the
globe's 30 mm right yes these guys this
guy's circumnavigated the globe one and
a half times yeah a little actually yeah
more or less
but he's incredible it's like you
realize no good then why is he so he you
know that there's a physiological you
know advantages like he's he's small
he's really light but he likes running
more than almost anyone on earth like
you have to it has to be your most
favorite thing in the world to do that
over and over and over and over and over
so it's like look at folks that like
this is not the best analogy but like
folks who love playing video games who
just love them like no judgment they're
playing video games 16 hours a day
they become professionals and they're
playing seven days a week 16 hours a day
for like a year they love it they
absolutely love it and they can do it
they can find
variety they can find interest it's a
whole world of stimulation and
experience now the difference between us
and Ashby Hana is that most of us
there's a lot of video game players but
most of us haven't had that kind of
experience when we run for many people
it's pain its exertion but I learned a
lot by watching him you know it's like
he has learned to minimize all the
problems that we think are problems when
you run I kill get horrific blisters
there's you know heat affects this
chafing there's sweating there's
indigestion but he's learned to minimize
those problems consciously you know it's
like he's realized that those aren't
actually problems of a great magnitude
if you don't want them to be you take
care of it but problems in life
shouldn't diminish your potential for
achieving happiness I mean what sort of
a state even the best guys Paperboy I
finished paper boy that we're talking
about here what sort of a state are
their bodies in after 3100 miles yeah so
you know the the rule of thumb right is
like when you when you race a marathon
for example 26.2 miles they say
anecdotally you need about 26 days
before your body feels normal he needs
like 1 day per mile with a 30 100 mile
race for the most part the average
person doesn't start feeling normal
again until about 6 months you know some
people don't feel normal for the for a
year some people take 2 or 3 years to
recover you know you're not in a in a
hyper taxed aerobic state but your
endocrine system your glands your
adrenals are working overtime because
there's some stress like you're trying
to hit a certain number of miles per day
you realize you have to keep your mind
soft to do that
but you're also pounding your GI tract
with 10,000 calories a day when your
body is already suffering from
inflammation you know your kidneys are
taxed trying to process the toxins and
the water equivalent
gallons twenty liters you're not getting
much sleep you might stop even at 11:00
11:30 at night but then at home you're
taking care of all your foot problems
all your blisters you're getting
everything ready for the next day you
might not go to sleep until 12:30 or
1:00 a.m. and then you're up into 5:30
so you're doing 60 to 75 miles a day and
you're sleeping four and a half hours at
night but you know I haven't done 3100
but I've done six day races and my
experience and those is that when you
lay down no matter what side of your
body you're laying on it feels like
you're sleeping on broken glass and the
the recovery happens when you run so
it's a weird mindset where you're
resting but it's like you're it's not
real rest at all and even you're 15 20
minute breaks during the day are all
kind of just to calm your mind down like
you're not really gonna like heal during
that so you're destroying your body for
52 days and then you're spending the
rest of the time recovering yeah but
there are odd exceptions it's like there
was a guy who did it this last summer
who's done it a number of times before
he finished it in about 51 days 50 days
or so three weeks later he ran a 310
marathon to 36 hours after that 310
marathon and his marathons faster than
that his normal marathon but he ran the
310 marathon 36 hours later and he ran a
47 mile race and actually in between the
marathon and that 47 a mile race he ran
a hard 2 mile cross-country race so it
all depends in a person some people are
beasts some big guys night it's just
we're surrounded by people I'm really
enjoying this resurgence that endurance
events are having you know Ross Edgeley
is a good friend of mine recently swam
around the UK he did bimodal sleeping
six hours on six hours of sleep six
hours on six hours of sleep and just did
that for six months and that's that
what gets you around the UK I was
watching I encou documentary on and
Amazon Prime I think on Netflix going to
be about a guy who did 50 ironmans
back-to-back 50 days across 50 states in
the United States yeah I mean that
that's a different thing it's like the
50 Ironman is it's I would say that net
effort it's not as taxing as doing 52
days of running because you're you only
want you're only running 26 miles a day
and the rest of its not as stressful but
the logistics of that are crazy so it's
not even something that can be compared
on a physical level like the idea of the
stress on your body from day to day is
mind boggling okay I don't know mama
Amazon don't care if somebody did a
hundred Ironman in it you know across a
hundred days in the same spot it's
nowhere comparable to that you totally
right they watching the documentary the
thing that I get the sense of so I run
events that's my job right that's
exactly what I do and I could feel the
tension coming from how are we gonna get
like he starts in Hawaii that just came
from Hawaii to mainland like that's a
that's a long journey on its own that
that's that's a task to do by itself it
took me a full day to get there from LA
and yeah watching that the the tension
and and that sort of the logistical
problems I imagined that doing that kind
of a project you know we're talking we
began this discussion talking about
taking ourselves out of the cerebral
taking ourselves out of the mind and
into the heart like when your planes got
delayed and your kit isn't there like
that's the opposite that is you need to
tap into that cerebral side right you
can't use that as no one's ever been
stuck in a traffic jam and thought this
is a lovely meditative practice for me
right here or it's like when you start
your performance you have to be able to
dissociate from the mind entirely like
obviously the mind has some use like you
want you can't go through the logistics
if you don't really use your mind
but so much of the stress during the
rate during racing comes from the
nervous system so many of the cramp
reflexes come from the nervous system so
it's like being able to turn off the
mind like on cue is an absolute you know
gift of an ability looking at these
distance challenges taking it from
capture gaez recent breaking of the two
hour marathon barrier right up to the
event that we're talking about at the
moment to me there seems to be two broad
schools of approach to it one of them is
the formula 1 car approach which it
would appear that Nike used with braking
- and then the inea's 1:59 challenge
used as well which is very very specific
amounts of hydration that are tailored
to the particular athlete a shoe which
is incredibly honed and everything just
fine fine-tuned down to its most
component parts that they were taking
giving Kip show gave water letting him
take as much as he wanted then taking it
back measuring how much he drank and
then working out how much more he needed
to compensate so that's one side the
Formula one side then the other side is
what I would call the David Goggins
approach which is kind of just the ramen
noodles spit and sawdust that tape my
knees back together and get after it
approach your mailman from Helsinki
what's why does he fall on that spectrum
so it's a great question you know even
with Kip Jogi it's like we see them in
the performance being highly regulated
because they're trying to achieve a very
specific potentially unreachable goal
but as you'd referenced in his training
camp in Kenya it's a Spartan lifestyle
they're not measuring calories they're
eating a lot you know they're actually
getting a lot of joy from their food
they're eating a lot of traditional
foods unprocessed foods but they drink a
ton of very sugary milk tea and they eat
a ton of bread and toast so it's not a
highly regulated you know raw vegan you
know a plant-based plant-based they're
there they're getting joy from their
food and they're using their food as
fuel
bahan all lives in a little shack in the
woods in finland and i swear to god he
doesn't drink water he said water is
boring like why drink water when you can
drink soda he probably drinks about two
to three liters of soda a day
he always has like bars of chocolate
everywhere
he eats ramen two or three times a day
he just loves it he eats what he just
loves food he loves eating what he likes
to eat and so he gets this tremendous
amount of joy from what he does I mean
it's the example of looking at guys like
the comedian George Burns guys who lived
like a hundred drinking three or four of
glasses of whiskey a day three or four
cigars lots of steak but living with
this joyful exuberance living with this
like childlike quality in the case of
tiptoe gay and Ashbury huh no it's far
more Spartan it's far more simple their
needs are extraordinary extraordinarily
minimal but they get joy out of what
they get joy out of but it's just not
the same type of comfort that that I
might seek so do the guys who are doing
this particular event the 3100 race are
they using a recovery protocol if they
got the foam roller out in between are
they eating I mean is our mailman still
just living on ramen in chocolate and
and and coke while he's doing this event
well when he said that the the course
record in 2015 where he averaged almost
77 miles a day for 40 days people said
that he did so well because his handler
refused to give him coke as much as he
wanted okay so like that they kept him
off the sweets okay yeah we might have
weaned him off yeah but that's like if
it was up to him he did pizza and
cheesecake all day long but in terms of
recovery protocol you know it you know
people do take it very very seriously
he's an exception where he just takes a
multivitamin and he eats and drinks as
he as he sees fit a lot of other people
eat a very particular vegetarian diet
during the race they're very careful
about their sugar intake their
inflammatory response they're taking
lots of herbs lots of vitamins
there's lots and lots and lots of
massage at night some people have
masseuses or masseur is massage them for
the first hour of their sleep like
between 12:00 a.m. and 1:00 a.m. like
there's that there's a significant side
on the crew and and and handling side as
well mm-hmm but not for everybody how
many people under the race typically pay
yeah they get between 10 and 15 a year
the overall completion rate for the last
24 years now has been about 62% that
said you know if they're if in any year
there's 10 runners there'll be seven men
three women more or less in terms of the
split pretty much all the women complete
the race I would say maybe 75 to 80% of
the women's complete the race who enter
probably 50% of the men complete the
race so fewer women enter the race but
there's a higher percentage of finishers
there do you think that that is because
the men who entered the race are less
prepared their eyes are too big for
their stride perhaps or do you think
that there is more volatility with the
physiology of men than there is with
women when it comes to distance running
so that's a good question I'm not I'm
not sure I can answer that specifically
but I can answer a corollary like the
the the best times in the race like the
2530 best times are all men like the
women aren't close to the best times
there yet that said it's like in my own
opinion seeing this race and seeing
altered distance running across the last
24 24 25 years women are just beginning
to realize their potential you know it's
like numbers aside participation aside
like there's lots of social issues there
in terms of encouraging women but it's
like the women that get into it I think
naturally you measure yourself against
the people around you so you measure you
measure yourself against the men and
some people think that all they're gonna
ultimately be faster than we ever could
be but you see there's a handful of
women like there's a woman at Carly
Courtney
Walter who's she's not as fast as the
best ultra runners mail us for ultra
runners in the world but it's like you
get her into a race with you know maybe
not the best males but still elite males
and there's a very good chance that she
could beat them didn't Courtney to Alder
didn't didn't something crazy happen to
her vision
recently in a race yeah I mean everybody
has bonkers experiences but she was
blind for god knows how many minutes or
hours of a race but like like there's
people like Camille Heron who set the
u.s. women's 24-hour record of 163 miles
in 24 hours on a track the male record
for you know 20 years ago 30 years ago
in the US was 163 now I think it's like
173 or maybe a little bit more but she
actually feels like she can hit that so
like you know my it's my I guess
moderately controversial take on it is
that you'll see over the next four or
five years that women's times are gonna
just get better and better and better I
mean we saw in the Chicago Marathon the
Kenyan woman Brigitte coast guy she ran
to 14 like she broke the world record by
a minute in the woman's side but she was
running because the race is set up this
way she was actually running with the
elite men or not too far behind them
through the first 5k it's like there's
no there was there I can't speak for her
but it's like there's very little
difference in her mind between the way
she can run and the way elite men can
run so I think more and more women that
kind of get into races the more will see
that even though there is a gap and many
pro ultra woman runners will say like
the gap is always gonna be there just
because of physiology the gap is gonna
get smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller
I think the specifics with regards to
men and women men's and women's
physiology as well it does lend itself
to these real long distances evening out
some of those physiological differences
because it is going to be so much more
dependent on what your mindset can
do right like so Alex Hutchinson is
actually going to be on tomorrow we're
going to be discussing in detail Kip
showcased most recent performance and
the implications of the shoe and also
it's this other stuff but in endurance
his book he uses the descriptor of
endurance as the will to continue
against a mounting desire to stop if
that's what it that's so that's not a
function of you Bo - max you lactate
threshold you're running gay economic
economic s-- whatever it might be none
of that
it's your will to continue against a
mounting desire to stop and there's no
reason to say that men or women will
have any advantage over each other in
that particular area I suppose when we
see weight lifters stepping up to the
plate things like bone density muscle
mass testosterone levels stuff like that
those really are have a pronounced
difference then but when we're talking
about a race that takes place over you
know fifty days it's gonna be a lot more
in terms of where can you put yourself
mentally yeah yeah for sure and I look
at the thirty one hundred mile race like
climbing a mountain very very few people
are at the level where people work where
they can say like I climbed that
mountain faster than you and and they
and they do do that and and those types
of people their achievements are
incredible but for the other ninety nine
point five percent it's like just going
up and down the mountain is enough and
so I look at the thirty one hundred that
way it's like there was a woman named
super Bob Eckhart an American woman
based in Washington DC who ran the race
the first 13 years and she finished all
13 times 13 times I mean it's just like
you know it's a it is an incredible
incredible achievement and I look at
that as akin to someone climb the
Everest 13 times like I don't care if it
took her five days or a hundred days
it's like just the mindset to be able to
endure that many miles across that many
days it's an incredible achievement so
talking about sort of rounding off the
event itself are there any
sponsors are I've never heard of this
race before but it's the sort of thing
that I would be interested in why is it
not more publicized is that purposeful
then you know doing the race is hard and
pulling off the race is hard enough to
do no matter what and they get 10 to 15
runners every year every few years is a
big article like there was one recently
last year in the BBC every this one of
the New York Times every other year the
Washington Post Wall Street Journal The
Guardian I think has covered the race
but it's so out there that it's more of
a thing that people really have to come
to see to experience and you know
because of the the movie coming out in
the States last year 2018 there were
hundreds of visitors they actually came
out to watch the 30 100 last summer and
people brought food picnic baskets sat
on the benches and it's one of the most
oddly entertaining events to spectator
because it literally feels like you're
in a temple for human achievement it's
like you can see Kipchoge a run the two
hour marathon once in your lifetime and
that's an incomparable experience and
having if someone was there in Austria
and it's just just a thrill but it's
like that same type of ethos that he
brings to his races on a different level
is present at the 3100 mile course like
everyone on that course believes in
their heart and in their feet that no
human being is limited and that's what
the atmosphere is like there so you can
spend a minute or an hour there it's
like going to the beach you go like I'm
not I can spend five hours at the beach
what happens nothing but I feel good
it's a really good analogy so as we move
forward with this is this the longest
race on the planet yeah it's the longest
officially certified race there is a
cross-country us race from San Francisco
to New York City people end up running
anywhere between 3050 and 30 100-mile
to actually do that but they can the the
they can choose any course they want to
so it's it's not it's a great race but
it's not officially sanctioned by
distance like this is I understand is
there anything else that you think is
there anything beyond this have you
heard any rumors anywhere this is it
this this frightens to many people in
and of itself you know it's like people
who are incredible specialists at a
hundred or 200 miles or five days or 10
days some appreciate the race some are
totally frightened by it and I think
we're gonna see a number of top ranked
American and international multi-day
specialist and ultra runners beginning
to come to this race as the fear factor
dissipates I don't know how you can look
at 30 100 miles in 52 days and not have
fear in the back of your mind I mean
that's like the marathon monks these
monks in Japan it's like a fear is in
the back of their mind during the
thousand day Trek they're dead they
literally have to kill themselves it's
like you have to get to that starting
line you know and be so full of joy and
surrendered saying like I might finish
the 3100 I might not it's not up to me
I'm gonna give it my best I'm gonna
exert myself but like the Hopi elder
rectally I'm say was said I'm gonna find
joy in that exertion and that's the
purpose it's like it can be a great
transformative experience whether
someone hits that 30 100 miles or comes
close yeah it's interesting so to round
off the discussion one thing for me is
someone who I'm interested in sports I'm
interested in human athletic
accomplishments but really as a person
who's not into distance running I think
are like there's a marathon and then
there's like a 50 and then there's like
a hundred and that's kind of it and it's
like it's just there's this long stuff
and then there's everything before that
but now there really is this these ultra
events you know we've got the Berkeley
marathon
guys have just recently released that
thing where you have to do a number of
miles per hour
yeah actually it's called the big
backyards and Cortney dal Walter won it
pretty recently you it's it's I think
it's a four-point one-mile loop in the
backyard of Lazarus that the founder of
the Berkeley Marathon and you had that
it's in one hour cycles you have an hour
to complete the four point one and you
have to show up to do your next lap
precisely on the hour so if you finish
it super fast
that's your rest time if you don't quite
make it you don't get to start the next
lap so it's really a race of attrition
so what happened a couple years ago was
Cortney dog Walter was neck-and-neck
with the male leader and a number of
people dropped out and they pushed it to
God I people will have to look it up
themselves but a couple hundred miles it
was they were over 60 hours no sleep or
whatever sleep you can get in between
your return and the start of the next
hour now here's the kicker let's say you
and I are doing it at it's 11:00 p.m.
and you finish at 11:55 I don't get
there you don't win the race you have to
start at 12:00 and finish that last lap
solo if you don't make it before 1:00 no
one wins the race no way yes oh it's
beautiful that way and these types of
like unsanctioned unregulated races
really are much more similar to the
types of things that we used to do in
running like the Native Americans and
the Bushmen would look at running as a
game it wasn't just point-to-point like
won against the world there is one type
of race that was done in the indigenous
northeast of the United States where
there would be teams of three or four
and there would be maybe 10 teams and
there's one corn bushel and we'd all
started the same place and the team that
carries a corn bushel across the finish
line
maybe ten miles away
they draw straws to see who has to carry
the corn bushel from beginning but you
have to capture the corn bushel from the
other runners so it's a matter of like
I'm not gonna try to take it from you at
the beginning but I'm not gonna let you
cross at the end so there's a lot of
intricate strategy and there's a lot of
wrestling it's like you literally have
to rest the bushel away from the other
team so it's these things which are not
measured you can't say they had the
fastest time or that the slowest time
but it's much more about running and
play and strategy then what most of us
have been used to in like schoolyard
running I wonder how many more people
would enjoy running if that was the
ethos that was brought to it well that
that that in that that's that's become
rugby right it's you know so you're
right so it's like you know the more we
can broaden running the more we can look
at obstacle course racing the more we
can kind of broaden out this exploration
of the world
on our feet and the more we can bring
spirituality into our feet and into our
breath I think the more we'll get out of
the multifarious world of endurance
running couldn't agree more
so Sanjay where can people watch the
3,100 race it will have 50/50 UK us
listening so why should the head so to
watch 3,100 running become in both parts
of the world you can download it on
Amazon you can download it on iTunes
it's available right now mid-october to
stream on Amazon Prime in the US and it
will be streamable and Amazon Prime in
the UK by mid November amazing well I
will leave the links if I want to find
them I would leave the links to where
you can go and check that out
in the show notes below if anyone wants
to follow you online Sanjay where should
the head at mr. Sanjay or or at 3100
film amazing thank you so much it's been
it's been absolutely awesome I'm gonna
I'm looking forward to when the the
documentary comes out and good luck with
the rest of the promo for it
the ultimately aggressive is great to be
on your show
[Music]
you